PROFESSOR: So in this
final segment today,
we're going to talk about
set theory just a little bit.
Because if you're going
to take a math class,
if you're going to be exposed
to math for computer science,
it's useful to have
at least a glimmering
of what the foundations of
math looks like, how it starts
and how it gets justified.
And that's what set theory does.
In addition, we will see
that the diagonal argument
that we've already made much
of played a crucial role
in the development and
understanding of set theory.
So let's begin
with an issue that
plays an important role in set
theory and in computer science,
having to do with the
idea of taking a function
and applying it to itself,
or having something
refer to itself.
And this is one of these things
that's notoriously doubtful.
There's all these paradoxes.
But maybe the
simplest one is when I
assert this statement is false.
And the question is,
it true or false?
Well, if it's true,
then it's false.
And if it's false,
then it's true.
And we get a kind of buzzer.
It's not possible to figure
out whether this statement is
true or false.
I think we would deny
that it was a proposition.
So that's a hint that
there's something
suspicious about self-reference,
self-application, and so one.
On the other hand,
it's worth remembering
that in computer science,
we take this for granted.
So let's look at an example.
Here's a simple example
of a list in Scheme
Lisp notation, meaning it's
a list of three things, 0, 1,
and 2.
And the black parens
indicate that we're thinking
of it as an ordered list.
Now the way that I would
represent a list like that
in memory, typically, is
by using these things are
called cons cells.
So a cons cell has
these two parts.
The left hand part
points to the value
in that location in the list.
So this first cons
cell points to 0,
which is the first
element in the list.
The second component of the cons
cell points to the next element
to the list.
And so here you see 1
pointing to the third element
of the list.
And there you see 2.
And that little nil
marker indicates
that's the end of the list.
So that's a simple
representation
of a list of length three
with three con cells.
One of the things that
computer science lets
you do and many
languages let you do
is you can manipulate
these pointers.
So using the language
of Scheme, what I can do
is I'll do an operation called
setcar where I'm taking,
in this case, I'm setting
the second element of L, that
is this cons cell, to
L. And setcar is saying,
let's change what the element in
the left hand part of this cell
is.
This is where the value
of the second element is.
Let's change the value of
the second element to be L.
What does that mean as
a pointer manipulation?
Well, it's pretty simple.
I just move this
pointer to point
to the beginning of
the list L. And now
I have an interesting
situation, because this list now
is a list it consists
of 0 and L And 2.
It's a list that has
itself as a member.
And it makes perfect sense.
And if you sort of
expand that out,
L is this list
that begins with 0.
And then its second element
is a list that begins with 0.
And the second
element of that list
is a list that begins
with 0, and so on.
And then the third
element of L is 2,
and the third element of
the second element of L
is 2, and so on.
It's an interesting
infinite nested structure
that's nicely represented by
this finite circular list.
Let's look at another example
where, in computer science,
we actually apply
things to themselves.
So let's define the
composition operator.
And again, I'm using notation
from the language Scheme.
I want to take two functions f
and g that take one argument.
I'm going to define
their composition.
The way that I
compose f and g is
I define a new function, h
of x, which is going to be
the composition of h and g.
The way I defined h
of x is I say apply
f to g applied to x
and return the value h.
So this is a compose
is a procedure that
takes two procedures f and g and
returns their composition, h.
OK, let's practice.
Suppose that I compose
the square function that
maps x to x squared, and
the add1 function that
maps x to x plus 1.
Well, if I compose the
square of adding 1,
and I apply it to 3, what I'm
saying is let's add 1 to 3,
and then square it.
And I get 3 plus 1 squared, or
16, because the add1 and then
square it is the function
that's the composition of square
and add1.
Now I can do the following.
I could compose
square with itself.
If I take the function,
square it, and square that,
I'm really taking
the fourth power.
So if I apply the function
composed of square square to 3,
I get 3 square square, or
81, or 3 to the fourth.
All makes perfect sense.
Well now let's define a compose
it with itself operation.
I'm going to call it comp2.
comp2 takes one function f.
And the definition of
comp2 is compose f with f.
And if I then apply
comp2 to square and 3,
it's saying, OK, compose
square and square.
We just did that.
That was the fourth power.
Apply it 3.
I get 81.
And now we can do
some weird stuff.
Because suppose that I
apply comp2 to comp2,
and then apply that to
add1, and apply that to 3.
Well that one's a
little hard to follow,
and I'm going to let
you think it through.
But comp2 of comp2 is
compose something four times.
And when you do that
with add1, what happens
is that you're adding
1 four times to 3.
If I comp2 of comp2
of square, I'm
composing square with
itself, and then composing
that with itself.
I'm really squaring four times.
And I wind up with 2
to the fourth, or 16,
is the power that I'm taking.
And so compose2 of
compose2 of square of 3
is this rather large
number, 3 to the 16th.
It could be a little bit
tricky to think through,
but it all makes perfect sense.
And it works just fine in
recursive programming languages
that allow this kind of
untyped or generically
typed composition.
So why is it that computer
scientists are so daring,
and mathematicians are so
timid about self-reference?
And the reason is
that mathematicians
have been traumatized by
Bertrand Russell because
of Russell's famous
paradox, which
we're now ready to look at.
So what Russell was
proposing, and it's
going to look just like a
diagonal argument is, Russell
said, let's let W be the
collection of sets s such
that s is not a member of s.
Now let's think about
that for a little bit.
Most sets are not
members of themselves.
Like the set of integers
is not a member of itself
because the only thing
in it are integers.
And the power set of integers
is not a member of itself
because every member of
the power set of integers
is a set of integers, whereas
is a set of sets
of those things.
So those familiar
sets are typically not
members of themselves.
But who knows, maybe
there are these weird sets
like the circular list,
or a function that
can compose with itself,
that is a member of itself.
Now let me step
back for a moment
and mention where did Russell
get thinking about this.
And it comes from the period
in the late 19th century
when mathematicians
and logicians
were trying to think about
confirming and establishing
the foundations of math.
What was math absolutely about?
What were the
fundamental objects
that mathematics
could be built from,
and what were the rules for
understanding those objects?
And it was pretty well
agreed that sets were it.
You could build
everything out of sets.
And you just needed
to understand sets,
and then you were in business.
And there was a
German mathematician
named Frege who tried
to demonstrate this
by developing a set
theory very carefully,
giving careful axioms
for what sets were.
And he showed how you
could build, out of sets,
you could build the integers.
And then you could
build rationals,
which are sort of just
pairs of integers.
And then you could
build real numbers
by taking collections
of rationals
that had at least upper bound.
And then you keep going.
You can build functions
and continuous functions.
And he showed how
you could build up
the basic structures of
mathematical analysis
and prove their basic theorems
in his formal set theory.
The problem was that Russell
came along and looked
at Frege's set theory, and came
up with the following paradox.
He defined W to be the
collection of s in sets
such that s is
not a member of s.
Frege would certainly have
said that's a well defined set,
and he will acknowledge
the W is a set.
And let's look at
what this means.
This is a diagonal argument.
So let's remember, by
this definition of W,
what we have is that
a set s is in W if
and only if s is
not a member of s.
OK, that's fine.
Then just let s be W.
And we immediately get
a contradiction that W is in W
if and only if W is not in W.
Poor Frege.
His book was a disaster.
Math is broken.
You can prove that
you're the pope.
You could prove that pigs
fly, verify programs crash.
Math is just broken.
It's not reliable.
You can prove anything
in Frege's system,
because it reached
a contradiction.
And from something false,
you can prove anything.
Well Frege had to book.
It was a vanity publication.
And the preface of it
had to be rewritten.
And he said look,
my system's broken.
And I know that.
And Russell showed
that unambiguously.
But I think that there's
still something here
that's salvageable.
And so I'm going
to publish a book.
But I apologize for
the fact that you
can't rely on the conclusions.
Poor Frege.
That was his life work
gone down the drain.
How do we resolve this?
What's wrong with this
apparent paradox of Russell's?
Well, the assumption
was that W was a set.
And that turns out to
be what we can doubt.
So the definition of W is that
for all sets W, s is in W if
and only if s is not in s.
And we got a contradiction by
saying OK, substitute W for s.
But that's allowed only if
you believe that W is a set.
Now it looks like
it ought to be,
because it's certainly well
defined by that formula.
But it was well
understood at the time
that that was the
fix to the paradox.
You just can't
allow W to be a set.
The problem was that W was
acknowledged by everybody
to be absolutely clearly
defined mathematically.
It was this bunch of sets.
And yet, we're going
to say it's not a set.
Well, it's OK.
That will fix Russell's paradox.
But it leaves us
with a much bigger
general philosophical
question is,
when it is a well defined
mathematical object a set,
and when isn't a set?
And that's what you need
sophisticated rules for.
When is it that
you're going to define
some collection of
elements, and you
could be sure it's a set, as
opposed to something else--
called a class by the
way-- which is basically
something that's too big to be
a set, because if it was a set,
it would contain itself and be
circular and self-referential.
Well, there's no simple
answer to this question
about what things are sets
and what are not sets.
But over time, by
the 1930s, people
had pretty much settled on a
very economical and persuasive
set of axioms for set theory
called the Zermelo-Fraenkel set
theory axiom.